means I'm speaking like Nakamura not
familiar with the codes you know
you should watch him so
this is a really cool chat you know just
because this was unbelievable I think it
was actually also in a yearbook just a
year ago when I played this um lindora's
everything
and then somehow like I miraculously go
to to the final where I had to play
Hikaru and it was sort of funny like you
sort of play uh play along the of Chess
and then
I would normally get to my room like
tired I fell in the bed and then I go to
the switch where anaka would normally go
to stream a little
and yeah this is okay chat this shot
that shot and watch out this was my
favorite thing so yeah no offense he
he's looking very nice thing for chess I
mean I'm becoming a big streamer but
still shots you know there are different
worst shots